and now forgotten English words and  phrases borborygmi a rumbling or  gurgling noise made by the movement of  fluid and gas in the intestines  Linna mania the obsessive desire to lie  down pet a conference to hold a meeting  while walking lunch scuttle to run with  an affected haste hoot KRA  the period right before dawn were one  lies awake worrying flim-flam nonsense  humbug  try pewdie 8 to trample an opponent in  triumph fugacious tending to disappear  fleeting smudge to lie snug or quiet sky  Bosch practical joking or tomfoolery  voyage to the Spice Islands  eighteenth-century slang for going to  the bathroom  enough of this fiddle faddle